panic from the Trump camp is growing
over what is clearly a strengthening
movement of electoral revolt against
Donald Trump last week on November 30th
I told you about a source that
communicated to me that there were 15
Republican Trump electors that had
quietly formed a coalition to revolt
against Trump on December 19th and we're
also working on convincing other
electors on December 1st that notion was
confirmed to me by a well-placed and
historically successful Democratic
operative and yesterday or the day
before I believe it was the day before
or was it yesterday
in any case yesterday I told you about a
Republican Trump elector from Texas
Christopher soprano said I am an
individual who is expected to vote for
Trump on December 19th and I will not be
voting for Trump this entire story
continues to get oxygen and spread
number one we will talk through it
Politico reporting that advocates of
this bid for an electoral revolt have
been in contact with close allies of
Hillary Clinton according to multiple
sources familiar with the discussions
now you might remember and I told you
this either last week or the week before
that the Clinton camp and the DNC both
have refused to endorse these efforts
spearheaded by number one groups of
electors in Colorado and Washington
State to revolt in the electoral college
they has said after I guess during or
after Jill Stein raised the money for at
least some of the recounts they said we
support the doing of recount but were
not alleging that there was voter fraud
we're not expecting the results to
change etc etc they now are taking
briefings about what is upcoming
potentially with this ellaktor over vote
in addition to that we have a law firm
offering free legal advice to electors
that are considering revolting against
Donald Trump we heard about this from
Lawrence Lessig who's a Harvard Law
School professor heading up the project
and he was interviewed by The Huffington
Post and said that the law firm do
tangley is handling intake of electors
that are considering voting in a
different way than the popular vote in
their state went they may end up
representing the elector I told you
about yesterday Christopher Sapru n--
and the idea here Pat is different
states have different rules as we've
talked about about what the punishments
are if any for electors who choose to go
in a different direction
sometimes a misdemeanor sometimes
potentially a thousand dollar fine and
what the law firm is saying here is if
you're thinking about this we will help
you for free to figure out what might or
might not happen and that's very
interesting
yeah these misdemeanors and fines would
go on the record presumably but it would
be for a noble cause and I think very
worth it this continues to also grow as
we now see in the New York Times which
published yesterday a piece in the
opinion pages by Elizabeth Williamson
outlining specifically how the electoral
college could dump Trump and she talks
about the legality of it I won't sort of
rehash that because we've talked about
that many many times but she made three
main points number one and I don't think
any of us are missing this this is a
very very very long shot number two that
after all Republicans do control the
House of Representatives and that if
somehow Donald Trump was denied the 270
electoral votes that he needs to become
President of the United States that
ultimately the House of Representatives
would more than likely still select
Trump and that if they didn't it would
not go to Hillary Clinton because even
if the 270 were denied to Trump and even
if the House of Representatives decided
not to vote in Trump it would be
probably some other Republican and were
really getting way way way ahead of
ourselves but the important thing here
Pat and the fascinating thing is when
this started on November 30th with my
source talking about 15 electors there
was a very little discussion of this
almost no discussion whatsoever and over
time our stories on this have gotten
more and more attention more and more
articles have come out about it and now
this is a real discussion that is
happening the Clinton campaign is being
briefed there is growing concern from
the Trump camp this is a real thing that
at least is being discussed yeah it's a
story that's now
starting to gain traction and the
interesting angle to is who of the who
are these electors going to vote for
yeah who are they going to pick I mean
presumably it's not gonna be Hillary
Clinton right who are they gonna go with
and that's where the speculation comes
that you may see a combination of
revolting Republican electors and
potentially some revolting Hillary
electors all of whom say let's vote for
someone else and every indication is
that if that were to happen it would be
some other Republican who exactly not
totally clear Kasich has said don't vote
for me some people talking about Mitt
Romney it's scary when Mitt Romney has
become the sort of sane and rational
choice that's really really crazy but
that's the America that we are in today
the holidays are closing in you can skip
the crowds the hassle the parking the
lines the annoying other shoppers as
well with Sheree's berries you can
choose fresh berries dipped in white
milk or dark chocolate topped with
chocolate chips the decorative swizzle
or chopped nuts
not just berries they've also added some
amazing seasonal treats just in time for
the holidays you can pre-schedule
a delivery day and the gift from
Sherry's berries will be delivered fresh
and on time guaranteed and there is only
one way to get the great 1999 Sherry's
berries deal and help to support the
David Pakman show go to Berry's dot-com
BERR IES dot-com click on the microphone
in the top right hand corner and type in
none other than my code which is pakman
PA que ma n Sherry's has something for
everyone
and most tastes I have to tell you as
well you can go to berries dot-com click
on the microphone and type in Pakman PA
que ma n for the 1999 Sherry's berries
special